[Music]
thank you
I'm not going to say it merch just
looking at it what do I have up
I'm not gonna say it
just finished his house yes
here's what we have
let me read the title
sister and brother-in-law visit dad in
his bedroom and I vent a camera about
violence and egos
oh good
right here here we go
let's just turned my brother-in-law
downstairs I can hear them laughing down
there talking to my dad and you can hear
their kids downstairs but we've
mentioned this before but the one thing
about all those videos is in every video
everybody else is laughing and having
fun but in every single clip it's like
he and he acts like it's the most
Sinister thing in the [ __ ] world they
start enjoying themselves they sound
like especially like in this day and age
they sound like a pretty good family you
know like you're close with their family
and they take care of each other
[Music]
the two of them my sister and my
brother-in-law
physically shoved me around in this
house
oh my God
it's not his brother anymore now he's
saying his sister and his brother-in-law
both shove him around in the house now
they're hitting him shifting they've
escalated now they're beating him in
this house
months ago
um I'm not I'm not on speaking terms of
them they are completely indifferent to
that fact because they shoved me around
right in front of our parents
you know what happened he's probably
been ignoring him and secretly filming
him and their brother because
brother-in-law like what I would do
would be I would be like hey come on do
the little shove come on man come on
we're all cool come on bro you know you
know what I mean like you did your buddy
come on bro bro come on dude stop being
an idiot oh my skin my Skin's flying off
every time you hit him he's so dusty it
looks like LeBron when he claps his
hands
it looks like when the teacher cleans
the drug the [ __ ] the erasers for the
trucks
will you dump out your vacuum yeah keep
this stuff on record and they know I
keep it on record and they have the
audacity not give a [ __ ] about any of it
yeah they are very deeply he really is
dustier than the Holy Grail
you just don't care
they negatively affect themselves in the
process of negatively affecting another
person
he's so dusty his entire body is made
out of black people elbow skin care
they keep pretending like
not saying matters that's what it was
when God made day in hypernova he's like
all we have leftovers black people elbow
scared just make a guy to that it's fine
just patch it up and have fun just get
the we need to get these units out
okay but listen all we have is punchable
faces that's all we have do we use that
yeah just a bunchable face is fine
when all of this matters all of this
matters
trans lives matter I got 50 Bentleys in
the West Indies it doesn't matter and
it's awful that people ignore it
Dayton we They're laughing it's off of
the people ignore the years mom laugh
I keep this on record
this is a very severe message
disgusting in different people who
participate in it ignore what has
happened when it's happening
absolutely disgusting people no
consciences
how does he live like this here we go
we're gonna see him today let's see what
he looks like
[Laughter]
[Music]
I know sorry
might as well just face the camera right
now
absolutely disgraceful we struck her to
his teeth so you know he's mad he's old
but like it's just look at the face all
day like this
taper I want this to be the clip thing
okay this photo okay thank you
all day every day just like this I live
like this
answer the man Virgie
what huh
oh he's sighing he's not having it
he's so mad
it's like you know what it is man he's
always Moody and he's always like moping
and it's like he has been waiting for 30
plus years for somebody to go oh what's
wrong yeah and it just nobody cares
well remember somebody did remember his
from remember the very beginning of this
and I for some reason one with so much
stuff I forget a lot of things but one
of the things I do remember was him
moving out with his friends and then his
friends kicking him out and evicting him
because he was insufferable to live with
remember that through all this he said
they threw all the stuff on the yard and
you have to move him back home yeah
because he's awful
listen to these monsters
listen to these monsters
here we go let's go let's go let's go so
I just started recording this forever
I'm just not working with that Corey
Feldman drip that Corey Feldman yeah
it's like Corey summon drip that Corey
velvet drip is amazing
I never hear my parents talking to
someone downstairs well turns out I can
tell by yeah because that's also what
his [ __ ] parents call him they call
him The Comeback Kid they keep kicking
them out and he keeps coming back
come back come back here
like I know you are that's the problem
who's talking downstairs that it's uh
they're loyal their their friend who's a
lawyer he's one of the very few liberal
Friends of the family well yeah he's a
lawyer at all and I haven't seen him
around here in a long time yeah because
they're they're having him come over to
start to helping them fill out the
eviction paperwork for you Dayton that's
why the lawyer prints there
so all you hear downstairs is like
so 30 days right he has to be out on 30
days yeah 30. technically it's 60. you
have to allow 60 days so for it to move
to the courts and then uh at that point
uh no later than 60 days they're
probably talking about Trump down there
and being white supremacist I love Trump
trans people yeah I know you know this
is legally binding I mean and if the
cops the cops are the sheriffs do they
come with the process service
probably talking about January 6th
Insurrection how much they were how much
January 6 was great for them that's so
funny I love that they threw a party on
January 6. I mean it also was my
birthday but still my brother used to
beat me and I didn't even care I didn't
care
he would have been at the Capitol if if
he didn't die of
[Laughter]
I mean I think he by the way I'm kidding
we're doing a character by the way
YouTube
Hey taper bleep that out please thank
you
more or less stayed away from the
skinhead because I think he noticed that
there was a skinhead living in the house
well he hasn't been around here a long
time I wake up and I'm just like I hear
him talking downstairs them so he's down
there talking to him for the first time
a long time so they're all reminiscing
about oh my God he's down there talking
that son of a [ __ ] in their home where
they live [ __ ] these people how do
they live like that I mean they seem to
be very happy
very sensible no I meant with [ __ ]
Dayton in the house oh it's just I mean
they tune them out if you think about it
like data makes it seem like he they
hate him but honestly they probably
never see him he probably is all like
Dayton is like basically the oldest
teenager he's probably in his room
listening to his Marilyn Manson and
eating his favorite brand of Health
burritos like he only comes downstairs
to get more Health burritos I I like to
picture him like the evil twin Bart yes
yes exactly Vincent [ __ ] and they stick
the head the health burritos in the
[ __ ] vent like the fish
every time the lights turn on he Scurry
he's like a roach
right over here
over here I'm talking about um
that used to hang out with the black guy
that [ __ ] his sister yeah that's the
one you see virtue remembers
called home
and said he asked if he could move back
in and you know my mom basically uh you
know at the beginning of this video I
can tell like from
overhearing it that she was starting to
talk about how uh you know what you what
is it what are you going to do you're
gonna of course you're gonna let your
son move back home or whatever like you
can see asks if she can move home and
I turn it on turn the camera around
because I was thinking maybe oh my God
they asked his younger brother to move
back home and he's pissed now because
now he he also eats his younger brother
even those younger brothers like from
Seattle and super woke but he hates him
because he's another one that does that
does doesn't acknowledge this guy's fake
story
um but now he goes okay so now now my
younger brother's gonna come back and
he's going to beat me in this house
the problem is he's mad that his brother
is gonna also live off the parents yes
no that no no no CeCe here's the thing
Marsh his brother wouldn't live off the
parents because his brother has a remote
job and he would still be making money
and paying to live there Dana of course
I just meant like but he's gonna be
there taking up he's going to be eating
some of the health burritos and we've
got a ration resources more now and he's
going to be mad about it Dayton you're
35 you're too old to have middle child
syndrome for real they keep talking
about it I think they kind of change the
subject there anyway uh the thing is he
moved home at their discretion and
within a week or two of being in the
house he beat me
he beat him in the house
or peanut butter years
I mean they were standing right there
and he was beating me
so he just won't let it go yeah
he beat me again so badly that I had to
go to the emergency room for a broken
bone
where's the police report did you file
one
they didn't kick him out after that
because because you broke a wine glass
over his head he was shaving his head
and shouting extremely racist stuff like
extremely like
uh just insane like what KKK stuff
KKK stuff you know
but you use like what
really insane like extermination of
Muslims and blacks and shouted by the
top as long as parents and they would
not do anything
I mean they'd shot back at them but they
wouldn't do anything or they'd just be
quiet while they did well this is at the
beginning of him living here so I would
if I you know was angry enough from
hearing what he was saying I would shout
back at him while he would beat me so
the first two times he beat me I said
you know
a matter of months but then he kept
beating me and those were only for those
were only the first two times and every
time he beat me he was like a more
intense beating so I don't know how I'd
only ended up in the emergency room uh
one of those times because you're so
tough you're built for it you're built
for tough yeah you're basically
Wolverine
except your bones are made of animanium
and your skin is made of [ __ ] wax
paper yeah you're basically Wolverine
you keep coming back and nobody's asking
for it
yeah seriously we we got it Hugh Jackman
we got it even Wolverine had the decency
to die in the last one [ __ ] seriously